are taken in round two in the 2019 draft
joining us now because the minnesota
vikings play the seattle seahawks on
sunday night football on nbc our good
friend paul allen who will be calling
the game remotely right you don't go to
the road games you're doing the radio
call from where where do you do it from
from the box box at u.s bank stadium and
uh same place we call the home games and
um you know the the first one against
indianapolis we have uh the tv copy and
an all 22 coaches angle
and it was tricky now the second one
against uh with houston i thought it got
better but it but bus 2020.
yeah that's how it all works and uh you
do a great job with the call that's the
only compliment you're ever going to get
out of me tell me about the vikings
plans and let's start with
dk metcalf because he really is
unstoppable you throw in tyler locket
and you look at the issues the vikings
have had in the secondary this year with
all the turnover and the reliance on
young corners
i got any chance to slow these guys down
or is this just going to be who can
score the most points
man i mean when you come into a game led
by mike zimmer and you got eric
hendricks who will play i mean you're
supposed to have a chance now i mean no
denial no anthony barr barr for sure for
the season to kneel maybe i mean it
makes it tough obviously and then you
got those young corners so the you know
the thing is mike with this offense with
cook and feeling and jefferson it um it
gives you a chance right now into the
second quarter of the season to stay in
these games and win these games as the
defense continues to mature so i think
it's going to be really high scoring
saying the team's going to go there with
or without the 12s and beat seattle for
the first time in a decade and a half
that's tough to do
hey paul the seahawks are obviously
struggling on defense they're dead last
32nd and total defense
decent against the run but they've
really struggled against the pass
cuz's last week had 260 yards which is
his season high is this a game maybe we
see kirk cousins break out and and
really be the guy for them uh this week
hi sharane um excellent question because
it was posed to me earlier with that
seattle nice run defense with bobby
wagner kj wright quandre diggs and puna
ford uh you know what uh vikings left
tackle riley reef right tackle brian
o'neill and center garrett bradbury in
the run game are playing at an amazingly
high level so that's what kubiak does he
runs and those guys are good so is
dalvin so you run at him now from a past
defense standpoint uh they they clearly
have found ways to get cousins around
not being a straight pocket drop guy and
to put up yards and points and and i'm
just you know when i heard russell
wilson talking about dk metcalf i mean
with all due respect to dk in the second
year ethelen is markedly more
accomplished than him and this justin
jefferson might be rookie of the year so
when i heard russell talking about dk it
reminded me of people talking about
thielen and jefferson
yeah you know what paul though i'd still
take d.k metcalf and tyler lock at over
thielen and jefferson all due respect
they they they are all for
very good but there's something special
about metcalf and i think the ceiling
for him is unlimited i don't think
you're right on that and and i rarely
argue with you because your lawyer
raised and you always beat me but tyler
and or dk have had russell all their
careers adam has not so to do what adam
has done despite the tumultuous nature
of this offense at times i've been
waiting to say this for 19 years
you're wrong
and i'm right and shireen's always right
you know i'm in a good mood today and
i'm being courteous to you since it's
your first visit to pftp so i'm not
going to engage your other further your
hair your hair really is fabulous today
i'm glad it's i'm i'm glad it's not like
i've seen some photos where it's like
albert einstein on steroids but what was
going to be often
but then when i knew shireen was part of
this i'm like all right a little bit of
gel some hairspray 54 years of age
serena will appreciate it michael be
envious now mike's had nice hair though
i'm older than you i'm 55. yeah he's
younger than us how about that
yeah i know i know
you don't you don't look younger than us
you don't you don't look i will say this
completely with these get off my lawn
type old man jakes yeah i know you're
older than me
hey
tell me what happened to the offense
between the first two games in the last
two games because i was ready to give up
i was i was saying tank for trevor until
they woke up the last two weeks
it's a great question but i mean
seriously speaking okay aaron rodgers
performance in that first game of the
whatever i've called in 19 years it's
the most in control dominating
quarterback performance i've ever
witnessed live in my life both teams
farv breeze came in here in 2011 and
kind of did it but so so they came into
it completely squared away with the
vikings and all that youth and no
preseason and that virtual offseason and
riley reef situation you know getting
taken care of a little late it just
didn't click initially then in tennessee
they hold him to six field goals sadly
one was a game-winner and the offense
gets going and the identity's there with
dalvin and jefferson blows up so you
just had to wait man because of no
preseason games for gladney and dantzler
and unique and gawkway got here like 72
hours before the first game and
jefferson and so on so that that's the
answer whether people want to accept it
or not
you alluded to in guaca
how much have they missed or have they
missed daniel hunter and everson griffin
i think those were their two leading
sackers last year
yeah well without denial it's been
devastating now you know the the daniel
hunter situation popped up right at the
beginning of training camp they were coy
about it as you know sharing you've
covered it forever they don't they're
not obligated to give injury info
at that time of the uh progression um
but those in the know kind of knew it
was bad and it might be like season long
bad but for now it's four games um and
then everson you know they had every
chance and everson had every chance to
come here and they had every chance to
resign him and it just never worked out
so i don't really know how that worked
out and you know i texted everson who i
like a lot god bless you man and best of
luck in dallas i want to see him do well
but now when gawkway comes in and he's
different than anything we've had with
daniel and everson because in gawkway's
pass-rushing guy that's who he is but
now specifically against wilson as you
know you got to get that contained man
and andre patterson the co-coordinator
and the d-line coach i ain't kidding you
he's the best in the nfl and everybody
will say it including george edwards
down there in dallas so patterson is
kind of raising in gawkways overall
games getting better but again you got
to be patient
i tried to convince myself to pick the
vikings this week because of the fact
that the
vikings are going to seattle without the
12s without the the noise the sound it's
deafening out there even if there's just
10 000 people the way they've designed
that stadium
but i just couldn't ultimately do it i i
i just feel like the seahawks offense
will outperform the vikings offense even
though the seahawks defense
isn't
very good right now
and it'll be a lot better when it gets
jamal adams back i just couldn't pull
the trigger i think the vikings cover
the spread
not that that matters in the standings
but make the case
as to why i'm wrong on that point that
the vikings will win and if you're right
we'll never mention it again if you're
wrong we'll play the tape monday
i mean you know let's be square here
michael and shireen is
without this fan base and vikings
quarterback kirk cousins has done some
great things specifically
the last year and change
and but he does have the fidgety gene
okay now there are no twelves
now the injury report for
seattle i mean it's like that okay so
they're either not playing or they're
playing hurt
and they have the buy next week
i mean if you can't really really get
them or go right down to the wire in an
epic game uh on sunday night football
with florio on tv
then it's probably never gonna happen in
that situation because our offense is
i'm not kidding you man if our offense
goes in there and we run up like 310
yards and 17 points
i mean i head in there absolutely
convinced this jefferson feeling
cook irv smith junior rudolph the way
the line's playing we're going to score
so if seattle wins it's going to have to
score 35 or more mark my words
yeah and i think it is going to be a
high scoring game paul we look forward
to seeing it on sunday night i'm sure
all the vikings fans who listen to you
every week look forward to hearing you
call the game before we let you go
though
we're curious is there a is it awesome
no no no is there a dog behind you or to
your right is that a dog back there we
can't tell
yeti hey daddy
teddy hasn't moved is teddy alive
okay he's going to get teddy teddy looks
like a good boy but oh there's teddy
yeah what's up teddy
well teddy sure for his nap
big mean michaels
teddy's pissed teddy's like what did you
do to me what did you do to me yeah hi
teddy teddy's a good boy teddy
bye guys all right paul uh take care
teddy thanks
um all right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports